Hey. Thank you for your interest in becoming
a member of the Rawkode Academy.
My goal is to provide the best cloud
native learning materials
for everyone.
Whether you're just getting started or you have
a hundred commits to the Kubernetes project,
Rawkode Academy should be the best place for
you to come
and expand your knowledge, your skills, and your
experience
with hands on learning materials delivered to you
live and interactive.
I hope to make learning all the tools
and technique that you need to take your
career to the next stage as entertaining and
engaging as possible.
Starting in July, there will be courses,
guest tutorials,
and exclusive livestreams,
all coming to Rawkode Academy members.
You can join now at the sandbox level
for the smallest fee I could set on
YouTube's service. This gets you access to the
members lounge on Discord,
so please don't forget to connect your Discord
and YouTube accounts.
And, of course, remember to join the Rawkode.
Chat.
Subsequent member tiers,
incubating and graduated,
will launch shortly after.
But by joining now, you get to shape
and direct the course of content to come.
I look forward to chatting with you. Have
a wonderful day.